today we're going to talk about the true
cost of generative AI for the Enterprise
specifically focusing on large language
models and it's important for an
Enterprise to consider all of the costs
Beyond simply subscribing to a chatbot
llm like chat GPT I'd like to start with
a a quick story last week I was at a
wedding and no one could find the best
man we were in the the dinner and the
rehearsal and all of a sudden he came
out of the back room with his laptop and
he was in this back room
writing his bassmen speech on his laptop
using chat GPT and you know what it came
out fantastic for a consumer use like
writing a last minute speech or a funny
poem using a consumer chatbot is awesome
and that's why for the consumer use case
spending under $25 a month for Access
feels like a great deal because it is
but we're comparing Enterprise use
versus consumer use for the enterprise
we have to safeguard what putting into
production when we're dealing with
sensitive confidential and proprietary
data now it's essential for the business
to evaluate working with a platform
partner or vendor that is geared towards
the Enterprise and this comes with very
different cost factors than the Consumer
today we're going to touch on seven of
these important cost factors that
influence how to scale generative AI
across the Enterprise number one use
case what is it that you actually want
to do with generative AI number two
model size what type and parameter size
of the model are you leveraging three
pre-training costs are you looking to
build an llm from scratch four
inferencing this is the cost of
generating a response using the llm five
tuning which is the cost of adapting the
pre-train model to do new tasks six
hosting which is the cost of deploying
and maintaining that model and then
seven deployment are you going to be
deploying this in the cloud on SAS or on
premise now these are all areas to
consider and the first that we're going
to cover is use case now I can't tell
you how often I have sellers customers
come to me and ask me to create a
blanket statement for what generative AI
is going to cost them for their
Enterprise and what I say to that is
that this is very similar to walking
into a car dealership and asking how
much a vehicle is going to be
different use cases will require
different methods and are going to drive
different amounts of compute we need to
understand are you looking for a
convertible a truck off-roading leather
interior we need some specifics and my
recommendation here is to work with a
partner or a vendor that allows you to
participate in a pilot so that you can
identify all of your pain points and
first see if generative AI makes sense
as a solution this will give you the
opportunity to really Workshop out what
it needs to test and evaluate for your
Enterprise play around with different
models see what delivers the best
efficacy at the lowest cost and the
fastest speeds if you have access to an
entire workbench of models and numerous
tuning methods you won't be locked in
and you can do what's right for your
Enterprise and truly customize that now
we're going to move on to our second
cost driver which is evaluating model
size now when we talk about model size
the size and complexity of the
generative AI model can really impact
pricing and what we see here is that the
larger the model is the more parameters
it has and that's going to drive compute
and different resources so what we'll
find is that vendors will offer
different pricing tiers based on model
size so we can look here at some
examples right we have our smallest
model here which is flan where we see
this at 11 billion parameters we have
Granite which is a midle middle tier
size at 13 billion and then we have the
largest of them all llama 2 at 70
billion parameters and what's important
to know is that different models are
going to serve different use cases some
are better for language translation
others are better for Q&A and as you
move across different models you have
the opportunity to assess what's going
to best suit your use case so something
to look out for when assessing a vendor
or partner to work with is what's their
stance on model access specifically are
they locking you into one model for
every use case or do you have the option
to select what works best for you
another thing is to assess whether or
not they're continuously innovating on
their own proprietary models we found
that Innovation at the model level can
actually provide you with some key
advantages when it comes to domain
specific task generation and
experimenting with different parameter
sizes now we're going to go to our third
cost driver which is
pre-training this is the process of
building and training a foundation model
from
scratch now if we look at what this
means it's been very hos prohibitive for
a lot of Enterprises to do so because it
requires a tremendous amount of compute
time and effort and while this does give
Enterprises the control of the data used
to train an llm it does come with a cost
we can look at something that everyone's
familiar with gpt3 and if we look at
what some of these cost factors were it
was over a th000
gpus over a 30-day period and what this
particular 30-day period cost was over
4.6 million so we can see that this is
very very expensive and really why we
only see a few key players that have
emerged on the marketplace to take on
that challenge of pre-training llms from
scratch so if you're not going to
pre-train you can certainly leverage and
take advantage of an llm that's already
been tree pre-trained so now we'll move
on to the next cost factor of working
with a pre-trained llm which is
inferencing and when we talk about
inferencing we are talking about the
process that the model uses to
understand the prompt question and the
process that it uses to generate a
response so essentially this is how the
model figures out what it is that you
want and then uses its own knowledge to
create the answer inferencing operates
on a discrete unit of information that
we call a token and this is a common
industry term where one token roughly
equates to 3/4 of a word now you can
expand that out to identify that 100
tokens would equate to roughly 75 words
and if you're still trying to figure out
what that benchmarks into the entire
work of Shakespeare would come out to
roughly 900,000 words now the size of a
token can vary depending on which
tokenizer you use tokenizer refers to
the tool that actually converts the text
to a token but 3/4 of a word is a rough
rule of thumb that you can go off of now
when we talk about the cost for a single
inference it's important to note that
this includes the number of tokens in
both the
prompt and the completion which would be
the
output so important to note that it
covers both of those now there's one
other term that's important when we're
covering inferencing and that is prompt
engineering now when we talk about
prompt
engineering this is how we interact with
the prompt itself and this is an
industry term for really the methodology
used to craft effective prompts with the
ultimate goal of eliciting a desired
response from the llm what's important
to note here is that it does not touch
the parameters of the model itself it's
more like choosing the right words and
formatting how you ask the question to
really help the model better understand
and it's a really cost effective way to
achieve tailored results without
extensive model alteration and this is
different than tuning because it does
not require the high compute resources
or any of the hosting so now we're
moving on to cost Factor number five
which is tuning now when we talk about
tuning we're talking about the process
of adjusting the internal settings or
parameters of the model itself to really
improve performance tuning is measured
in hours and you'll often see that there
are different hourly rate charges
depending on what model size you're
using we talked earlier about how
different parameter sizes lead to
different cost increases now when you're
making the decision to
tune there maybe two reasons
why you would choose to do so so reason
number one maybe it's to achieve better
performance from your base model when we
talk about better
performance we're going to evaluate
whether or not tuning the model on a
large number of labeled data could
really enhance performance when we do
this we see that you can actually
optimize it by bringing in your own data
the other option for tuning may be to
evaluate whether or not you can lower
the cost at scale by deploying a smaller
model than maybe what you initially used
one thing that's really important to
keep in mind here is that the cost of
label data acquisition is a really
important factor now when we talk about
tuning there are two main functions of
tuning and two main methodologies of how
you can tune we have fine
tuning and then we have parameter
efficient fine-tuning otherwise known as
PFT now to cover the difference between
these two when we talk about fine-tuning
we're talking about extensive adaptation
of the model itself so you're tuning all
of the parameters and changing them
you're going to be generating a forked
version of this base model that actually
requires you to then go on and host that
and it
requires hundreds of thousands
of data points label data for you to
bring in here so this is ideal for
highly specialized tasks where
performance is critical when we talk
about parameter efficient fine-tuning
this really aims to achieve task
specific performance without the high
costs that are associated with extensive
fine-tuning and this is really achieved
by avoiding any changes to the model
itself so here you could think of this
as tuning smaller models by adding
additional parameters is not altering
what exists so for this you can see this
more around hundreds to thousands of
label data sources uh and we see
different types of cost-effective ways
to apply parameter efficient fine tuning
some of these types that you may have
heard of may include prefix tuning
prompt tuning ptuning Laura but these
are all methods of parameter efficient
fine-tuning so let's drive this home an
analogy let's say you buy a home you
move in congratulations everything's
perfect but after a couple of months you
discover that it actually snows quite a
bit more uh in your environment than
what you thought it would and it gets a
lot colder and initially you had windows
that served you quite well in the summer
but now that it's winter they no longer
work it's really drafty so you decide to
go and completely change the structure
of your windows you put new windows in
that provide you with insulation and you
even get some really nice curtains to go
along with that but on top of that it
snows so much more so now you actually
have to go on and buy a ton of new
equipment you have to buy snow plow snow
shovel snow boots snow tires and
actually build yourself a garage to
store all of this this is an example of
fine tuning in the sense that you are
making structural changes to the
architecture of your house how this
would relate to the model making
structural changes to the underlying
parameters if we look at what this would
mean for p well perhaps here you're not
going to do anything to actually change
the underlying structure maybe instead
of rebuilding your windows you put a
towel under there to block the draft
instead of building a garage to house
all of your new snow equipment maybe you
reuse something you already have and you
just use your broom and use that to
scrape snow away so it's helpful to
consider here that there's different
methods that make sense for different
use cases perhaps in some we mentioned
earlier you can get everything you need
in your output from prompt engineering
as you need to make your models tuned
for more specific use cases it's helpful
to have different methods of doing so
and working with a partner or vendor
that provides you with the ability to
explore different parameter efficient
fine-tuning methods as well as
fine-tuning for when you really need it
because then you have the advantage of
selecting the most cost effective method
for your needs now we're going to move
on to discuss evaluating factor six
which is when do you need to host a
model now there are different
circumstances that would require you to
actually have to host a model to then go
back and interact with it in these ways
that we discussed before for inferencing
and things of that sort now if you are
going to make an llm available for you
use there are two ways to go about doing
it one would be hosting it or one would
be using an inference API Each of which
becomes relevant depending on whether or
not you're going to fine-tune a model so
if you're not fine-tuning a model and
you're going to use some of those
earlier methods we discussed where maybe
you're using parameter efficient
fine-tuning or you're using prompt
engineering this is when you can go on
and us an API for inferencing and
essentially what this means is that
you're going to stay consistent with
those initial cost factors that we
described with the token unit of driving
price and cost and compute and here the
llm is predeployment
as you need it again as I mentioned the
cost for inference when you're using an
API inference is based on the number of
tokens that have been processed by The
Prompt plus the completion of that
prompt via the API call this again is
used when you're not making changes to
the underlying model so you're not
fine-tuning and you're not bringing
something new in that's not already
hosted by your platform the other way we
consider hosting is actually when it
becomes relevant when you are
fine-tuning or you are bringing your own
model at that point you are required to
then go and host that model because
you're essentially creating either a
forked version or bringing something new
in and in this case the llm is actually
made available for deployment by the
platform Provider by taking this in and
so for this you could think of it as
rather than phoning a friend because
they don't have access to a phone you
actually build them a room in your house
and that's where they are for easy
access whenever you need to chat them up
so when we're talking about how we think
about cost factors when you are actually
hosting a new forked version of the
model on top of what you use with your
tokens for prompting you also have to
consider in the hours that are required
for hosting this model and again you
would pay for hours based off of the
amount of time that you want to interact
with the model so if this is something
you need to interact with all the time
you'd be paying the hour cost for 24x7
access to this model now again it's it's
very important to realize that different
use cases and circumstances are going to
require different methods of connecting
to your model it's helpful to have a
vendor or partner that actually allows
you to interact with your model in
numerous ways if you do need to host it
with fine tuning to have that option but
you know if you can do an API inference
to also have the ability to access it in
that way as
well and now we've made it to our
seventh cost factor which is deployment
now when we think about deployment every
industry has different standards and
every business has different needs so we
are referring to where you're putting
the platform and the cost of using
generative AI can vary significantly
depending on whether you choose SAS or
an on-prem deployment so when we talk
about SAS there are some benefits here
when it comes to cost standpoint uh
first of all you're using a subscription
feed this is often a predictable and
manage
cost structure as you're paying that
recurring fee to access the AI service
you have a different approach to the
infrastructure here you're not going out
and procuring your own hardware and data
centers you are um avoiding that aspect
of the cost and when it comes to
scalability you have the ability to
increase or decrease usage as needed and
again all of the maintenance and updates
to the infrastructure are included the
big thing here is that when it comes to
generative AI a lot of people are
concerned about acquiring gpus with this
you don't need to go out and procure
your own gpus the SAS providers are
actually sharing those GPU resources
across multiple users so it ends up
being more cost effective for the end
user on the other end we have on premise
now for some Industries there are
regulations that require you to do
things on Prem and you're not allowed to
host your data in the cloud and for that
there are solutions out there for on
premise deployments as well what's
important to note here though is that
you are required to purchase and
maintain those gpus uh the amount of
which would be contingent to the amount
of compute that is required um based off
of your inferencing tuning model
selection but you do have the benefit
here of having full control over the
architecture and how your data is
deployed there are no black boxes so
again depending on your use case in
Industry you might have different needs
but the recommendation here is to find a
partner or vendor to work with that can
meet you where you're at that can
provide you with the opportunity to
leverage generative AI whether in the
cloud or on premise thank you for
watching if you've liked this video and
you want to see more like it please like
And subscribe if you have any questions
please drop them in the comments
below